[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
June 29th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
if home buyers already facing limited
choices in a tight Market are turning
away from so-called fixer-uppers Wall
Street Journal personal finance reporter
Veronica dagger joins us so Veronica
people have been buying Fixer-Upper
homes for decades there are even TV
shows about them why are they falling
out of favor with Buyers now well one of
the reasons is they just don't want to
hire a contractor it's a lot of work to
do that and it's hard to find them these
days but the big factor here is high
mortgage rates so buyers are already
spending a ton of money to get that
mortgage they're spending a ton of money
to buy the house some of these houses
they're paying a lot for it aren't in
the best condition but they're still
buying them anyway so if you're already
forking out a ton up front there's not a
whole lot in your budget left for
something like a renovation yeah like
you said it's a lot of work it's not
like just walking in and hey it's a new
home right exactly yeah there's so much
to do you have to find the right
contractor if you're working remotely I
mean that's something to think about too
do you want a construction site made out
of your home home anyone who's had work
done knows how difficult it is to get
contractors sometimes to commit to
certain timelines and certain costs so
that is discouraging people as well what
this means right now is that people in
general are backing away from buying
these renovated homes and are looking
for more of a turnkey home experience
let's talk a little bit more about
interest rates you mentioned that a
moment ago how are they affecting
fixer-uppers on the market so
fixer-uppers are already less favorable
for buyers these days because not only
you've got your high interest rate on
your home loan your mortgage rate is
higher than people paid about a year ago
but also typically when you renovate a
house you need to take a construction
loan and the rates on those loans have
also increased so you've got higher
construction loan costs you've got
higher mortgage rates you've also got
high property taxes higher property
prices all of these things are
pressuring buyers wallets not to mention
you still have inflation in other parts
of your budget depending on what sector
you work in you may be worried about
your job so there's just so much
pressure on buyers right now so they're
just not in the mood for any of this
what kind of a position is this putting
the sellers of fixer-uppers in so
basically what's happening now is that
if you're trying to sell a home and this
is true in many markets of the country
of course there's exceptions but in
general if you're selling a home that
needs repair it's going to sit on the
market a bit longer than one that's
already renovated unless you do some
work on it simple repairs can make your
home more salable so for example if you
refurbish the hardwood floors or you
update the landscaping or you even do
neutral colors to the paint like white
or Ivory that can help sell your home
faster all right so let's look at the
rest of the market how has the lower
appeal of fixer-uppers affected
renovated homes on the market so
renovated homes are selling pretty
quickly still especially in certain
areas of the country like Miami or New
York sometimes still seeing bidding wars
for certain houses if those houses have
the charm and they're in good shape
you're probably going to have to pay
more for those houses than ask and so in
that way it's definitely tilted more
towards a seller's market so if people
aren't remodeling these older homes the
fixer uppers how's that affecting the
Home Improvement in Home Remodeling
Industries what's interesting is that's
not really slowing down and the reason
being is that a lot of existing
homeowners are the ones doing the
renovations still and so you're
renovating your house because you want
to make that perfect home office or the
gym or what have you to your house and
so the market for Homeowner improvements
and repair projects in the US is
projected to reach 484 billion dollars
this year and that's up from 328 billion
dollars in 2019 so we can see the
pandemic had a big boosting effect on
this Market also people are staying in
their homes many people have these very
low interest rates mortgages something
like three percent even less than that
and so they are less motivated to move
if you're less motivated to move and
give up your mortgage you're gonna make
the most of your home and so you're
gonna keep doing renovations even though
it's really hard to find a good
contractor these days yeah if you got
that mortgage a couple years ago you
want to lock it in exactly why moved
it's these golden handcuffs that some of
my colleagues here have written about
there's no motivation to move especially
if you're going to have to move to a
smaller place paying a higher mortgage
rate and paying more for the house
there's just zero motivation but for
buyers can they afford to be choosy in
this market we keep hearing about low
inventory already limiting their choices
yeah so some buyers have to take
whatever they can get and that could be
a really dilapidated house in certain
cases so if you're in one of those
markets where those bidding wars are
common you still may have to pay top
dollar for an unrenovated house and you
may have no choice because this may be
the only thing you can afford the that's
Wall Street Journal personal finance
reporter Veronica dagger and that's your
money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the
Wall Street Journal
[Music]